I guess it depends on what way you're
doing it like if you're if if I'm like
so bait that I'm going after guys like
as in like I'm I kind of hunt you can
see that like all I'm there for is like
it's just for the money then but if you
ask women what they want one of the
first things they say is ambition why
aren't they shamed for that like the
same way a man if he says big tits he's
gonna be ashamed like the big titties
though
oh
um
I don't think they should be
the goal of it is to is to create as
unclean environment as possible to
inject whatever ideal Best Suits You So
if you're in a situation where the woman
wants you to say physic physical
physical
characteristics then it's corn if not
that's also cool so the point is to blur
the lies between reality so much that I
can actually tell you it's like
hypnotism you know I give you a lot of
words on top and then I actually slowly
inject what I actually want you to to do
that's why they don't they can't fit
with whether they want ambition or love
or kindness or a tour guy or just anyone
or good sex or protection
it's that's why
what do you guys think
um
I think
it's a bit of like accountability for
women I guess because like if guys are
open and it's okay for them to be like I
want a size six like I want a girl
that's size six or something that girls
have to do it
so like they're like okay don't say
anything that's so true because if men
say what they want then we have to do it
and the women don't want to like they
don't I feel like modern women are lazy
they're so late yeah
and women just love money
I don't get it or
ugly Rich guys
but I think with when they make money
will make him look pretty do you do you
just do you feel like you live in
reality
I just feel like I don't know I've just
I just threw up differently all right
listen
go to a therapist and like figure out
what your issue is with that word right
okay just figure it out
you're my patient tell me more about how
you feel please
why do you hate the word Fields because
because it's not what it is so you're
you're saying like the way I feel is
reality but let me let me change that
word because I'm using it in in place
for think right
I need to go back to what we were
talking about
um
she lost the kids
I think I think it's because
I've just been raised I've been raised
by like predominantly men right so I
even though I hear what everyone is
saying I don't think it's always true so
I've also been raised around women that
haven't are like quite traditional so
they're not really going for their men
because they because of their status or
because of money they're going for them
because they love them they get on
question so you're raised by men and
traditional women yeah but you have
tattoos and you think any more attention
is harassment what kind of man you know
what I feel like if I said to my dad oh
dad you know what these guys are
chatting to me in the street he would be
offended by that and he wouldn't be okay
with it sounds like a beta do you think
any dad wants their daughter to be no I
think I think it might have my dad would
say who cares that's something I would
say yeah like any I just think that's
like simp Behavior to like to yeah to
say to say that to say you have a right
to be offended because someone
complimented you that samp
you would want your child to be I would
I would I would tell my kid to get over
it like why do you want to be a victim
like modern women want to be victims
like who gives a [__] okay he
complimented you keep walking that's
what I'd say I want my I want my
children to suffer as much as possible
because I want hard suffer bro what I
had to suffer hustle bro like you want
them to feel it as well get bullied for
five years and then figure out I'll drop
in and give you some tips like a good
you know teacher and whatever you know
in the video games where the bot comes
in yeah let's bring back why would you
oh yeah let's bring back bullet I'm so
tired of these hoes never been humbled
ever in their life thank you everybody
just no no because honestly if you why
would you want this because if you've
never been told you ain't [__] you're
gonna think you're the [__] all the time
like sometimes you need someone to tell
you you ain't [__] you know how lucky I
was to be grow to grow up fat
now that humbles you but humble I'm so
glad I had a Brothers to tell me I was
ugly sometimes yeah that's what brothers
do yeah it builds characters guess what
I've got two of them yeah and I'm saying
but you're I'm saying let's bring it
back let's bring back bullying why thank
you Austin I appreciate you why why
not sorry I don't know
about human development brain
development is to understand your
players understand that you won't you
won't have like the mainstream view all
the time you can't have consensus that
chaos is really important for kids
growing up look I don't want to have the
mainstream view but I also don't think
bring back Boolean that's ridiculous
come on like bring it back I got bullied
I'm dope it's cool yeah
so maybe some of you have never not been
invited to a party in its shows some of
you have never showed up on Monday and
said wait there was something going on
this weekend
what'd you guys do and it shows it shows
like like why do you think men tease
each other like you women say oh it's
toxic masculinity we're trying to have
this consensus around not thinking and
doing things that are toxic no it's
because being teased teaches you to
distance yourself from words and what
you actually are they actually get hard
into it if I told my son your donkey
you're silly you're looking weak right
now in in the right way right I
encourage him what is the right word but
how is that the right way because you
don't know how that's going to affect
him that later on down the line personal
trainer says says you're looking weak
right now you can do one more you know
ex that kind of motivation but insulting
at the same time if the average at best
girl had been told she was average
before it wouldn't have been such a
shock yeah if she actually had to deal
with reality it wouldn't have been she
wouldn't have had to call into some
random guy's YouTube show to be told she
can't get a six-figure guy but that's
what happens when you let women live in
delusion for too long as they start
thinking they're they're qualified for
something they're not and you see it all
the time in like just day to day it
breeds self-awareness and you need that
you need self-awareness you can be
self-aware though without without being
in the book bullied but you don't even
let me call a girl a whale even though
they are why do I need to cook I feel
like I'm sorry I could say what I was in
my shows
what I'm saying like I don't have to
agree with it but you do that's the
crazy thing is you you know damn well
they're whales you know damn well
they're fat you know damn well that
they're less attractive because they're
fat I'm not saying you got to be a whale
forever I've been fat you can lose it
but see like why is this offensive this
shouldn't be offensive it just is it's
just a fact honestly you're fat you're
have you ever approached a guy and you
got rejected
no I don't think so no no I've got a
very short memory because that would
have been harassment because you would
have probably complimented that would
have been crazy you could have been like
why are these women just complimenting
me she said like how are you [__] I'm
cute what's going on here
imagine if men reacted the way women do
I I do that sometimes just to take the
piss like like I had I had this first uh
time where I was trying out this new
Theory so I was like how about I just
make women feel uncomfortable all the
time when they approach me for no reason
just just to see whether it has an
impact and turns out they love it
because when you make them feel
uncomfortable they think you're the
superior social mind they think your
higher status making people feel small
is a very effective way because yeah wow
because they're arrogant anyway so it's
like resorting to things like that
because of how the day Market currently
is
necessary that's fair enough right
because I guess like out of trauma or
whatever you're doing what you're like
you're not liking a circumstance
I mean